the jurogan experience
so you were 13 when you
you and your family you it was you and
your mother that escaped
yeah how did you get out so
the hospital right initially my sister
and i was going to escape but when north
koreans say when you are escaping
of course we don't have phones we don't
have a map we don't know what's the
outside world
look like right luckily i was living in
this border town of north korea by then
so at night do you know if you see the
satellite photo of north korea
it is the literally the darkest place on
earth yes
we don't have electricity so i was
seeing these lights coming from china
so we i thought like if i go where the
lights or
we would be finding some bowl of rice
so at 16 my sister left with her friend
and she left me a note while i was in
the hospital
and got like removing my appendix
and then as soon as i got out of the
hospital i found a note
and initially my mom and i went to look
for sister where she went
but when we found the lady she told me
that
she could help me to go to china that
day
and so this was you and your mother and
you were 13 years old yeah
so how did you get across and what is
that what was that experience like
so uh this is uh so i told my mom like
convinced me to china
and she my mom was like you know father
is like my father was
home he was waiting but the thing is
that's
the tragic thing for north korea we
cannot even say goodbye to our loved
ones
so if we got caught on the journey and
if my father knew that we were escaping
he's gonna be punished so much so it's
better off that he does not know that we
are escaping for his own safety
because they're gonna torture you to the
point that you're gonna say anything
because they do this all subconscious
like torture
that they make you not sleep in a single
room
has like no air much air if you put
there for 40 days
alone you go crazy you say whatever they
ask you
so if you he actually knew that you're
escaping it wasn't good for him
he would be dead so i told him i'm like
you cannot tell father that we are
escaping
so that day we climbed up this
exceptional mountains and then we went
to the riverside
but she had a connection with the guards
why did you not bring him with you
because he's a man and he was sick and
somehow she said only women can't go
only women can grow
i did not know why what she meant by
that she's like
you should just go with your mom and
don't even tell those people that's your
mom
she said like you are like 18 or
something and my mom was something 30 so
she told me that our wage with age was
different
so and this would somehow another help
you when you were going across
yeah how would that help you i don't
know
or she told me what this is going to be
helpful and
well part of the issue is um
in china there's a disproportionate
number of
men in comparison to women yeah and so
they want
as many women to come across
as that are uh of legal age
like women that can be married or can
write is that
the idea behind it it's it's a smuggling
so like it's easy you got it right
because of one child
policy right a lot of girls got aborted
in china
so they kept the boys so there's many
many men
that have no chance of ever finding a
woman because there are no women yeah
over 30 million men in the rural areas
cannot find the wives
so they over 30 million and it's never
gonna keep going up right now
so that's a big problem for chinese
region but the thing is
even that they don't allow north korean
women to stay there
they catch us and they send us back to
north korea last month
china repatriated the 50 north korean
defectors back in north korea
it is sending them our suits literally
they are sending them to death camp
but the chinese regime still do catch us
and send us back because they think
we are posing a threat to the regime and
they don't want the regime to collapse
so they are catching all the defectors
but the human traffickers see the
opportunity here because
we are so vulnerable right we are
running away from chinese authority
so even they rape us and kill us the
last place that we are gonna go is going
to police
and then report on them why did they
think
that women coming over from north korea
are going to somehow another collapse
the empire
because uh though that's what kim
jong-un believes he thinks they're going
to collapse through the defection
through the defectors so after kim jong
came into power
he literally the country cannot afford
the electricity
probably electrified the fence the
entire border
not only that putting the machine guns
through the guards have a
ticket order whoever crosses they don't
even bother to ask you stop they
shoot you right there and not only that
he bury the landmines
on top of that so there's electric
fence and then there's guards shooting
to kill and then past that there's land
mines
yeah entire country became a consensus
in camp
entire country when did they start
putting the land mines in
a few years ago so this is after you had
already escaped yeah
now there's no you can't you don't see
north korean defects escaping from north
korea anymore
it's impossible to escape at this point
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience